like with everybody one of my Donald
Trump alright huh how should the media
respond when Trump attacks a reporter or
organization good question you know that
press conference he had that we're at
rendering a new era at a press
conference in Fillmore right and also
you know the idea it's kind of genius of
like having your clock there to laugh at
you you know it's like what Howard Stern
does you know we've got a little kitchen
cabinet there where every move you
begged a great one Johnny that was a
good well if it's this classic I mean he
actually if you look in the textbook of
personality sorters he's narcissistic no
well so I don't need we don't need a
book have a policy wonk I like to look
at the bud road but you know I mean
that's one of the things that he does
right he actually has this shortage of
popularity in the real world and so he
is obsessed with the idea that he's
popular and so he creates this sort of
sense of a cacophony of support which is
just not true as today's barely-there
mall right showed but but to answer that
question everybody should have walked
out it would never happen it would not
have happened if I don't can't imagine
the circumstances any of the last five
presidents had done it because in those
press rooms it is now not about getting
an answer from the president but getting
yourself recorded and played on your own
network asking the question and the guy
could just go oh and they would run that
soundbite so there's no uniformity
there's no collectivism but if you now
Phil if you've now quadruple the press
room you guys walk out CNN walks out an
NBC ABC and CBS somehow go out with him
that leaves of 47 Jeff Ganon's to ask
questions right from the Bush
administration remember him yeah that's
who's going to fill those other things
yeah yeah well if anything is good about
this though it is I feel like the press
has been chastised and they got the
message I don't know if they're changing
okay they've changed to a degree already
yeah but they do feel bad and I never
seen him at least feel bad before they
do feel like oh yeah we did [ __ ] up we
we did overhyped the email [ __ ] and
we did over cover Donald Trump well look
what we got but they felt bad after Iraq
and it didn't last long it's really like
what uh Tom Sawyer said about Huck Finn
when an evangelical preacher came to
town the preacher was so good that Huck
was saved until Sunday afternoon so you
know it's just not a it's a bit hard to
stay on that wagon I think that there's
going to be a lot of terrific reporting
there has been a lot of terrific
reporting you look at what the
Washington Post did on the fact that
he's never given anything to charity the
New York Times had the GSA story today
that the President of the United States
as of now is in violation of a GSA lease
which explicitly says no federally
elected official can own one of these
contracts so the moment he took the oath
he was in violation of federal
regulations maybe that was one he
suspended that evening but I think that
a lot of it is on and we can talk about
this a lot of it's on us to people to
act on that information and not let get
it lost in the Trump State cacophony
well that's why I've been Johnny one
note here because Tommy one note I guess
because we can't normalize fake news we
can't allow the ethics breaches that
have occurred there's more ethics
breaches from the time of the election
to the time of the inauguration then
there I mean the Obama administration
was squeaky clean this guy is starting
square one and they've already violated
yeah every ethics ruling of the day but
we can't ask lots of organize in
particular so that's why you know I got
involved in this race for the DNC
because we've got to get out there and
organize organize organize but we also
have to be honest with ourselves as
Democrats still because we can we can
talk to or blue in the face about Donald
Trump's lack of character but we also
have to understand that you know on
Election Day we had folks that we didn't
touch you know we got enamored with data
analytics and we ignored the old
persuasion you know it's you can't go to
a church every fourth October and call
that an organizing strategy yeah we've
got to get back to basics and you look
at rural America you look at what's Khan
and we also have to shout down our
fringe the politically correct [ __ ]
well on the far left oh what's getting
more toward the center too many of them
look it wasn't even that popular here in
this room I I understand I mean I I
think we we we have to get out there and
make house calls because you know there
is a Howard County Iowa in 2012 went for
Obama by 21 points in 2016 went for
Trump by 21 points
that's a 42 point swing you can't sit
here and say all Donald Trump voters are
racist know that you know there's plenty
of Donald there's plenty of air even
Dukes out there but these folks that the
challenge was we didn't touch them we
didn't listen to them when Donald Trump
comes in and tells you in Butler County
Ohio which is coal country and
alienating your call [ __ ] and alia nated
many yeah right friendly they have this
impression that what in the heart not
that we don't care but that Democrats
are just always coddling a irresponsible
behavior they just have that impression
that the party of giveaways and the
party who just doesn't care about the
regular person anymore
and and when you talk about jobs you
know in Ohio for instance I was there
recently jobs jobs jobs was the number
one issue when Donald Trump comes in and
says I'm going to bring your coal jobs
back we know that's a lie
but what they heard that what they heard
from the Democrats was vote for me
because Donald Trump is scared what they
heard from the Democrats is we're going
to make you pee next to a guy in a dress
and that's our number one priority well
there's that too but they also heard or
intuited that at this point the
Democratic Party particularly that
embodied by the Democratic nominee not
her challenger in the primaries but by
the Democratic nominee that as George
Wallace once said there's not a dimes
worth of difference they see the elites
and that there's this duopoly that
ultimately is a plutocracy and so yet
the cultural stuff matters but when they
looked at Hillary there David marinus
did a great piece about the story of the
Clintons is when he went from McDonald's
to being a vegan and
that shift here lost a ton couldn't as
matters about McDonald diseases and
cultural signifies about NAFTA and
repealing glass-steagall I mean there's
actual policy change the face of the
secundo and the welfare and the welfare
and the crime bill and I just I want to
make sure that as we try to do this
analysis of what went wrong with the
Democrats we don't end up sort of
lionizing the kind of regular American
who is you know in all of our
imaginations like a you know middle-aged
white guy like this guy named Gary that
called into a c-span show that I was on
and said I'm a white male and I'm
prejudiced and you know you could hear a
pin drop on the set and he then went on
to say you know what's the gangs and the
drugs and you know repeating all the Fox
News stuff and then at the end he said I
actually want to change and be a better
American and I want to know if your
guess me can help me do that and then I
had a good on you all right I have a
birthday party to get to
[Applause]